they are thinking about investigating
Hillary Clinton do not adjust your
television do not uh uh go back 15
seconds on your podcast player it is May
of 2023 and they are looking at an
investigation into Bill and Hillary
Clinton Jim Jordan appeared standing and
with no suit jacket as he always does on
Maria bartiromo's show yesterday morning
on Fox News Maria Bartiromo is a Fox
News propagandist and Trump brown-noser
who screams most of the show I don't
know why you could just turn up her
microphone if you thought she needed
more volume and she gets Jim Jordan to
seemingly tease
that they're going to look into an
investigation into Hillary and maybe
Bill Clinton as well as you can see
House Republicans has taken control in
January they really have their fingers
on the pulse of the issues of importance
to the American people real quick
while they were pursuing Trump they made
no effort to investigate the claim that
Hillary Clinton was taking money from
Foreigners for her Captain Global
initiative and the Clinton Foundation
they not only did investigate her like
they did President Trump they gave her
oh they're both screaming today campaign
a defensive briefing right they should
have done the same for president Trump
because they literally he had no
evidence so we're going to talk with our
lawyers we're going to talk with speaker
McCarthy on where we proceed from from
here in fact are there people that were
that were highlighted in the Durham
investigation and the Durham report that
we need to talk to on the Judiciary
Committee we're going to give that a
good hard look but nothing is off the
table because yeah it is even Hillary's
on the table the American people
understand how their government their
agencies have been turned on them the
taxpayer and we get all the facts out
there Mr chairman real quick
uh I hope they finally get to the bottom
of the Lewinsky scandal I really do
because I've been waiting around
nobody's really given it a good hard
look and I think it's time that we
figure out what the hell happened back
in the 90s with Bill Clinton maybe go
back even further I want them to look at
some of the things that Hillary did when
Bill was governor of Arkansas because I
think that's really where the bodies are
buried as they love to say these people
they're nuts but I wouldn't put it past
them to actually try to investigate
Hillary